who's phones ringing
come on that's your phone my phone's on
backpack
no that's your phone yeah well look what
is this
what do you think this is this is
hollywood agq
i'm jacob balordi and i am going
undercover
on the internet this is actually me
[Music]
first up quora how can i be like noah
flynn
jackie baloti question mark my
girlfriend said he's like her dream guy
what are direct things that i can do to
be like that that's awful
i'm so sorry your girlfriend should
never say that you
are her dream guy don't listen to that
direct things that i can do to be like
that first of all don't be like no flynn
i wouldn't want to be like that in real
life if you like jacob lordy
don't do that either hey be yourself man
submit
read it did the show make nate too evil
i just finished the show and i was
wondering does anyone else think they
made nate
too much of a villain i don't think that
they made nate too evil no i think he
has the perfect balance of
terrible things happening to him and he
reacts accordingly to the things that
are happening
in his life obviously he doesn't have
much of a moral conscience but
i think his evil actions are justified
by sort of what happens to him i don't
really think he's a villain either
love or hate nate as a character jacob
lordy's performance during his meltdown
scene with his dad
was phenomenal acting i wonder how many
times they shot it
super unlucky if he hurt himself on the
first nail intake they did eric and i
did that
scene over 10 times from different
angles but we were really lucky because
it kind of started in a
in a place where we didn't really know
what it was or what the scene
was going to be and then by the end of
it we exhausted ourselves and
physically exerted ourselves and
mentally exerted ourselves and it ended
up
in the place that it that it was so
it kind of needed to be a lot of tapes
for that scene to work i think
i'm super proud of of the whole show i'm
just
super happy to you know to be a part of
it because everyone to me in that show i
think is just phenomenal so it's kind of
like
pinch yourself all the time when you sit
back and you realize that you get to be
a part
of the same show as then youtube how
tall is he i used to be so sensitive
about my heart because when i first
started acting literally everybody would
tell me that i'd never work
because uh they wouldn't wouldn't be
able to like partner me with people and
they wouldn't lift
the camera up so i basically got told
that i was too tall to be an actor
so to all of those people nice
so yeah i was super nervous about
telling people my height so i used to
try to pass as like
six two or six three but i'm actually
six five
so online there's all different kinds of
um of
numbers because i've just sold myself
out here
just because i i didn't want anyone so
because people hear six five and they go
like
you're a giant but if i stand next to
someone who's six three the difference
is like tiny
this is from hooks could anyone else see
jacob as batman he's a very talented
actor thanks
that's so nice of you i really
appreciate that probably like the one
thing that you want people to say about
you ever
is what you just said so thank you very
much i'd love to be batman
huge batman fan batman is the one
superhero thing that i actually have
time for
and enjoy so that actually is really
cool
this is from jackie body on his favorite
things in life
he can cook husband material crying
emoji no
actually i can't cook at all the extent
of my cooking is
jam on toast if you want to sign up for
a life of
really well lathered butter and jam on
toast then yeah absolutely i love the
material
i don't like that you're crying about me
being husband material though that seems
toxic
i look like such a knob in these photos
under here
they're like super steely
next up imdb he learned how to ride a
motorbike
for the film the kissing booth that's
true i did we were in south africa
the guy just his name was neil maybe
just threw me on a motorbike and he was
like just kind of figure it out
on the side of the freeway somewhere in
uh
in south africa and it was awesome uh
fella a million times but yeah i did
learn how to ride them for that movie i
don't ride them my mom won't let me
i really want a motorbike though i'd
never ride one in la but i would like to
get one
he started acting professionally by
playing the cat in the hat
in seussical by far the standout
performance of the show
professional is uh an interesting word
i was in grade six but yeah why not
we'll go with that
moving on instagram when are you gonna
start working on season two of euphoria
i have no idea i hope it's really really
soon
because i'm really bored and i'd love to
go and do that i had the scripts
for euphoria season two but that was at
the start of the year and they change
all the time so i imagine now it's a
completely different show
is it possible that you're now 59 years
old and used to be called
michael schoeffling laughing crying
emoji
oh the guy from 16 candles yeah that's
me i'm him you're looking at him he's
doing a gq interview
how you like your eggs cooked in the
morning i don't please don't cook my
eggs i'll make my own breakfast
oh it's
they want to like be like um
help me in that regard okay
um
thanks thanks so much i thought they
were genuinely wondering
how i like to have my breakfast twitter
what kind of girl do you think jacob
lordy likes
it's girls like me right right he likes
me
i like you wikipedia
the lordy was born in brisbane
queensland australia on 26th of june
1997 to john and melissa elordi he has
two sisters
he is of spanish descent that's not true
i have basque descent which is this
little place
between france and spain my grandfather
would strangle me
if he knew that it said spanish descent
so i have three sisters
they're all much older than me i'm not
much older but relatively
much older growing up as the baby i was
definitely spoiled i'm still spoiled
i've never
not been spoiled and i plan to be
spoiled for the rest of my life
next he attended secondary school at
saint kevin's college
and nudgy he showed interest in acting
since he was young and was involved in
many school dramas
yes i did i lived in melbourne for uh
for a little while my sister
was a ballet dancer at the australian
ballet school so
our whole family moved from brisbane to
melbourne
and i went to school at st kevin's which
was super strict
and then in grades 11 and 12 i came back
to brisbane and i went to nanji college
which was not super strict
i did showed interest in acting since he
was young and i was involved
in many many school dramas on and off
the stage
korea this section on wikipedia is super
short i don't know what that's about
the lordy's first appearance in a
hollywood film was in pirates of the
caribbean dead men tell me tales
[Music]
you know this is something that i've
wanted to clear up for years people are
always trying to find me in the movie
and there's screenshots of me
in the movie no i was in the background
of the movie i wasn't in the movie i
wasn't credited i wasn't billed
i didn't audition i was an extra
and it was one of the best things i've
ever done in my entire life
and you'll never find me i don't know if
it counts but the first movie i ever
made was um
stefan elliott and it was called
flammable children in which i played
a lifeguard again
not much of a performance just kind of
standing there
wait what is it called swinging safari
what did i say it's cool
it was called flammable children did it
change its name
there you go i'm getting old i can't
remember
i've been in that many movies now submit
hey that's me signing off the internet
guys thank you so much for
uh for tuning in and listening to me
talk about myself
uh thank you gq and
have a good one